(playful music)
- Alright, thank you everybody for coming.
If we have anybody who's
still in the memorabilia room,
the exhibition hall,
we encourage you to come
into the lecture hall here
and join us as we kick off
the third annual symposium
on hybrid scholarship at Yale
University: Beyond Boundaries.
And this event is one that
is organized every year
by a team led by Kathy DeRose
who's the manager of the
Digital Humanities Lab.
This event for the last three years
really has been the work of Kathy
and it's been supported
by a great team of others
inside and outside the lab.
We're especially happy to
work alongside Yale STEAM
which is a student led group
here at Yale University.
STEAM, as most of you know,
stands for STEM plus arts and humanities
with a silent H.
We're really excited to
be working with them.
It helped us in putting
together the program
for today's events.
So the exciting thing about
Beyond Boundaries of course
is that it brings together
folks from all parts of
the scholarly spectrum
at Yale University
and today you're gonna hear talks
in round table discussions,
for folks who work in our robust museums,
galleries and libraries organizations,
you're gonna hear from undergraduates,
graduate students and faculty.
It's really exciting
to have all these parts
of what makes Yale
University great here today.
When Kathy asked me to
welcome you all to the hall,
I asked her what are
the things I need to do
because you're organized everything,
you've managed to get the room renovated,
all this great program, really excited.
What could I possibly
do that would be useful?
And she said, "Two things.
"The first thing to do
"is to make sure that
everybody's powerpoint works."
So I'm going to be up here
as we switch between different
keynote presentations,
different lightning talks
to make sure that everybody's
powerpoint is working well.
And she said the other
thing you need to do
is to keep us on track.
So for all of our wonderful
lightning talk presenters,
I'm gonna have little one minute warnings
and then this is the cane
that yanks you off the stage
just so we can get
through everybody's work.
And so with that, I'd like to
kick off our lightning talks
which are gonna be
presentations by students
and post doctoral associates
on subjects related to digital humanities
and STEAM projects here at Yale.
And the first of our lightning talks
is going to be science stories using IIIF
and Wikidata
to create a linked data web application.
And this is gonna be a presentation
by Kenneth Seals-Nutt and Kat Thornton.
So Ken and Kat, come on up.
- Hello everyone.
Thank you for allowing me to
speak at this opportunity.
My name is Kenneth Seals-Nutt.
I'm a senior, a computer science major
and I'm working in
concurrent with Kat Thornton
who is a CLIR fellow of computer science
as well as in the digital
preservation department
in the library.
And what we have been
working on this past year
is called science stories
and what that is is a application
that we're gonna leverage two resources
that are widely used by
other projects here at Yale.
The first being Wikidata
and the second being the IIIF framework
and I'll touch a little
bit on what each one is
as well as give a brief demo
of the application and
what we've built so far.
So first off I'd like to start
by just explaining the team again.
Kat Thornton is a CLIR
fellow of computer science,
I'm a senior undergrad student here
and this also doubles as my senior project
for the computer science department
and Professor Benedict Brown
is our faculty advisor for this.
So I'll first give the high
level goals of the project
and then break it down
into what things are being
used within the project.
So our first goal
is making a visual
storytelling application
of academic research.
One thing that we found
with today's great resources of computing
as well as a lot of frameworks
that have been built on the web
is that we can renovate
how we go about explaining
our scientific and academic
research to the public.
One thing that we found
is we all do great research
here in these institutions
but if someone that doesn't
have access to Yale's catalog
or another catalog of interests,
it's really difficult and cumbersome
to find out this information.
So our first goal was using
images, videos, multimedia
and incorporating that
with our academic research
to paint the picture of who
we're actually researching
and provide more contextual
information there.
And then we're also gonna expand this out
using the Wikimedia to
crowdsource some of the content.
One thing that is really beneficial
of a lot of research projects
is these stories can be told
and a lot of people don't have
to do all of the busy work
or all of the overhead work
of finding out all of the information
that other people have already researched.
So if we can find a way to
leverage more crowdsource content
and incorporate that with scholarly
and academic research,
we'll be able to tell
more about the person
and I'll also demo how IIIF connects
a lot of research institutions
together through this
and allows for authorship
as well as annotations and citations
to be transferred from
institution to institution
in a very safe way
that allows a lot of interactivity
for the users as well.
And so ultimately the goal
is to bridge the gap between information
that's currently in print,
digitizing that and putting it on the web
and making it accessible
and the project as a whole,
the main reason why we
decided to go about this
is to celebrate 150 years of women at Yale
which is coming up next year.
So what we wanted to do
is Kat has been doing research
on the early women at Yale
for the past two years
and she approached me
with the research that she's been doing
and I thought it was
completely fascinating
and we both came to the consensus
that more people
should be able to know
about this information
and not just be able to
read a paper about it
but also be able to interact with it.
So we're starting this project
on these first five women
because they have resources
in a lot of different
areas on Yale's campus
and so we're starting here
to show that we can leverage
all of Yale's research
across the library as well
as the Peabody Museum,
as well as the department and the faculty
to all have a part in telling the story,
not just a library or not
just a museum on campus.
And so first, I'll explain a little bit
about what Wikidata is
for those of you all who do not know.
A lot of people are
familiar with Wikipedia,
the English Wikipedia.
Wikidata is another one of the projects
that the Wikimedia Foundation has adopted
and what it is is it's machine
readable open link data
and that's a long phrase
but essentially it allows people
to create these statements
and my mouse shows,
for example, this is Grace Hopper's item
on Wikidata right now.
And so it's very clear statements
of what the bare bones
data is about this person.
And it goes on pretty lengthy
but it just gives you an idea.
So for example, like
instance of human, image
and then it has the link to it,
sex, gender, female.
So now we can feed that
information to a computer
and it's all unique identified
with these identifiers here.
So that allows not only humans to be able
to read and understand this information
but also using algorithms
to curate this data
as well as to know that you've hit
exactly what you're looking for
in terms of research.
And then we're coupling this
with using IIIF
which stands for
the International Image
Interoperability Framework
and what that does
is it's a standard set of image APIs
that a lot of research
institutions came together
to determine this is how we're gonna
transfer the meta data about our pictures
when we're sharing these images.
So instead of having
people just copy and paste
or download images off the web,
now you can export a JSON package
that has all of the meta data.
So that includes the licensing,
descriptions of what is
actually in the images
outside of just a caption,
links to where this resource is.
For example, if it's digitized,
we can link back to what
the actual collection is
in the archive that it's
being referenced to.
So I like this picture on the side here
'cause it shows how we
can make this practical.
For example, this is a display
in Boston College right now
where as you know,
you can't really have the public handle
really old manuscripts and text
so this would give you the possibility
to digitize that information
and have users flip through
the book page by page
in a much more interactive
and personal manner
than just by staring at
whatever page that's there.
And so I will quickly just explain
that what our application does
is it's going to give you the ability
to combine both the information
on the Wikimedia Foundation,
YouTube videos, as well as books
and any other content that we
can find all into one place.
And I'll just do a brief
demo of what that looks like.
Right now, this is in a prototype phase.
So it takes you to this landing page
and right off the bat,
it shows the first five women
that we're planning to do research on
and when you click on them it shows you
a little description about who there is
and it's pulling this
information from Wikipedia
and then you can view their story here.
And we decided to go the slides method.
So you click through
and these are all not just for one person,
these are just to show the extent
of how the application is gonna work.
So this is all not for one person
but for example, this is a
IIIF image viewer right here
and you can hover over who's in the image
and understand more about the content
and click on it and as well
as have all of the information
on how to cite the source
and give credits and attributions.
And then on the very last slide,
it'll show you all of the
current Wikidata information
about them.
So yeah, that's where we're headed,
what we've built so far
and we're planning to present this
the first official demo of
our first five science stories
at the Women's Faculty Forum in May
as well as we'll be
presenting the full prototype
at the IIIF Conference in D.C.
And we're submitting a
paper tonight actually
for presenting this
to the International Semantic
Web Conference in October.
So thank you guys very much for my time.
(audience applause)
- Let's just jump ahead to Amy Giuliano
who's gonna be speaking on
abroad but now accessible
VR educational tours,
- My name's Amy Giuliano.
I study religion in the visual arts
here at Yale University
and I wanted to begin by inviting you
to imagine that you're standing
at the threshold of St.
Peter's Basilica in Rome.
You see bronze doors,
monumental bronze doors
towering at five times
your height above you,
and a guide beckons you into a wide nave
pierced with shafts of light
and immediately directs
your attention to the right
where you see Michelangelo's Pieta.
As you walk around this masterpiece
and consider its various angles,
the guide describes to you
the genius of Michelangelo
and of renaissance humanism.
So what I just described to you
is the dream of one of my students,
let's see, her name's Alex.
Alex longs to study abroad in Rome
and especially wants to
study some of the art
and architecture of the city.
However, costs and opportunity
prevent her from doing so.
And Alex is not alone.
In fact, less than two
percent of US college students
study abroad annually.
The obstacles for most
are cost, opportunity and access.
So I lived in Italy for several years,
I'm an Italian citizen,
I worked for years as an art
historical guide in Italy,
specifically in Rome
but some of the other major cities.
I currently teach at
Sacred Heart University
in Fairfield, Connecticut
as an adjunct professor
and my frustration
was that I really wanted
to share with my students
the transformative learning experience
of being within the living classroom
that certain incredible cities provide.
So I felt frustrated that
so many of my students
were missing out on this
transformative learning experience.
So I decided to tackle the problem head on
and I'll present to you
my proposed solution.
So two weeks ago I went to Rome
with some kind of high
tech photography equipment
and created 3D virtual reality tours
of some of the major sites
of artistic, historic
and cultural significance
around the city.
Using 3D high resolution photography,
laser scanning, 360 photography,
I virtually reconstructed
some of the interiors of these sites
and made a virtual tour.
So I'm coupling this
immersive visual experience
with an interactive virtual tour.
So students feel
as though they're walking
through a 3D space
and they can stop, click and
explore points of interest
that are linked to audio,
visual and written content.
So here are some of the
sites that I covered
while I was in Rome.
Major sites of mostly
historical significance
but also historic and
cultural significance as well.
And I chose two to share with you.
Here we have a classic for
any art history course,
the mausoleum of Santa Costanza
It's a fourth century building.
And I'm just gonna go through,
I won't give you the tour
'cause we don't have time
but I can explain to you
some of the advantages
of using this type of technology.
As you can see,
the student moves around the space
and can look all the way around, oops,
if I can get the mouse
to work, there we go.
There's these buttons here
that allow you to zoom in
for high resolution detail.
You can zoom to different areas.
There's a highlight reel.
You can kind of see how it works here.
So this church took about
two hours to complete.
This is a replica of the
sepulchre of costanza
which is now in the Vatican museums.
Sorry the mouse is a
little difficult on here
but you can kind of see what I mean.
Here we have Santa Maria sopra Minerva
which is a huge church,
it's a basilica in Rome.
It has works by Michelangelo,
Filippino Lippi,
the grave of Catherine of
Siena and Fra Angelico.
Here's a dollhouse view and a floor plan.
You can see that just as an example
because I'm currently working
on creating the interactive tours
with audio, visual and
textual elements added
that I put a little tag here.
And so the student can
go into that chapel,
look at these 14th century,
excuse me, 15th century frescoes, 1493.
I brought my students in here
specifically because we were reading
so many Summa contra
Gentiles by Thomas Aquinas.
and here he is
and it's an illustration of that work.
So they'd explore these frescoes,
you can zoom in for very high detail
if the computer doesn't
crash, here we are.
And again, you can see
the tag that I put in
is just an example,
oop, there we go,
of you click and read
all about this space.
These little areas on the floor
indicate places where
you can zoom in and out
and kind of the next step in the tour.
I'll bring you to the altar
and then we'll leave this space.
Here's Catherine of Siena's
body underneath the altar.
And again, I'm setting this up
so that students can see this
in virtual reality headsets.
So the experience will be
really three dimensional.
If you turn around here,
this is Christ the
Redeemer by Michelangelo.
So walking you through this,
I'm trying to give a
sense of the advantages
of using this sort of
tool, pedagogical tool.
Let me jump back to my presentation.
These are my students
exploring the Minerva
as they read Summa contra Gentiles.
And again, some of the advantages
include this is an immersive,
unforgettable experience,
it's interactive,
it's engaging,
it does what video cannot,
you're not passively
going through a space,
you're really interacting with it,
you're exploring.
It's high resolution,
you can explore sculptures
at different angles,
you can consider your scale,
you can consider the context of yourself
within this enormous space
and my little plug to you
is please help me give access to students
to sites that they may
otherwise never experience.
And here are some of my students.
I'm pleased, just to conclude,
I'm pleased to announce
that I've received a
fellowship with Sci City
to work on this project for
two months over the summer
and kind of get it off the ground,
make some more tours.
So thank you.
(audience applause)
- Thanks so much to Amy.
And now we'll move on to the media concept
which is gonna be presented
with work from Anna Shechtman
and Zachary Kitt.
- Thank you and thanks so much
to Peter and Kathy and Doug
and everyone at the DH lab.
Unfortunately my partner Zach Kitt
who is at the Jackson Institute
at Yale can't be here.
He was a programmer before coming to Yale
and he's actually just about to graduate
and be a programmer again
and he has been working with me,
I'm a PhD candidate in English literature
and film and media studies
and I am working on a dissertation
that is called the media concept
that's about the evolution
of the term media
in the second half of the 20th century,
specifically about when
we enter the vernacular
and the ramifications that it had
for different culture industries.
So it's a very literal project,
it's very word based.
And so I actually was inspired
to work on it and think about it
because I was fooling
around on Ngram Viewer
which many of you may know,
just google interface here.
You'll see that around
after world war two,
there's this skyrocket in the
occurrences of the word media
in all the texts up to
2008 that Google Books has.
And so I was interested in that phenomenon
and also interested in
some of the iterations
or offshoots of the media concept
and their evolutions over time.
And so I wandered into the DH lab
and asked them about Ngram Viewer
and also if there was a way
to have more control over it
because it sort of just calls
from this massive amount of
text that is Google Books
and if you actually go in
and it allows you to sort of click around
and see which books in
particular it's calling from
and sometimes you'll see
that actually the meditative is wrong
and a book that it says
that is from 1940
is in fact a book from 1812
that was republished in 1940,
it's just not very precise.
And the fact that it goes up to 2008
is also not ideal
because it doesn't go up to the present
and that is for all sorts of reasons
involving copyright and law.
So I wanted more control
over Ngram Viewer and Google Books
and so I wandered into the DH Lab
and asked them if I could get that.
And they said that I would
have to build it essentially.
And so I learned about corpus,
I learned about corpora,
about building your own,
basically scraping text
from all aspects of the web
or if it's not digitized, digitizing it
and trying to create your
own database essentially
that then you can manipulate
with various different tools
all of which I'm still,
my learning curve, I will
admit, is still very steep
and very grateful to the patience
of both Zach, my assistant
and everyone at the DH Lab.
So I'll tell you a little bit
about what Zach and I have done.
We started with the Vogue corpus
which is available through the DH Lab,
thankfully Yale has that.
And so we have all of these PDFs
of articles from Vogue,
from the 20th century
and we actually ran a Google algorithm
called Word2vec.
Word embedding models
are as far as I can tell
the most interesting aspect
of the textual digital humanities,
they're just super exciting
because they allow those
who have any facility
with the algorithm
to track the semantic ands
and tactical relationships
of words over time.
How they do that is fairly complicated
and I can definitely
talk to you afterwards
and also would absolutely point you
to the blog posts of
Ryan Heuser from Stanford
and Ben Schmidt from Northeastern
who are really facile and agile
at writing in between the
lexicons of the humanities
and of the computer sciences.
But basically, they take all
of the words in your corpus
and they plot them visually
in a space of n dimensions,
multidimensional space.
The theory behind this is you
can actually get related words
from one query.
So I can query media
and find all the related words
and the principal is that
these semantic and syntactical evolutions
will be tracked by the company
that a word keeps over time.
And so here, we just query
media in this Vogue corpus.
You'll see one of the most
interesting things for me to find
is that in the '40s and '50s,
you get a lot of let's
say not very abstract,
pretty concrete nouns,
manuscripts, criticisms, palettes,
also, they're all plural.
And then as you move through time,
you start to get adjectives
and also adjectives that
might qualify as singular
like the consolidation of
media as a singular concept,
cultural, historical,
racial, political, religious.
To me that signals,
I mean this is not,
this is a small dataset
still, Vogue, right.
The word media might not
show up as much in Vogue
as it might in say the New York Times
but we're more moving in
that direction, Zach and I.
So to me that signals the
consolidation of a concept
because you have, it's being
qualified all of a sudden
opposed to being substituted
and metaphorically or
metonymically by other nouns.
So then here's where things
get really kind of
psychedelic and interesting.
So what Word2vec allows you
to play with is arithmetic
but linguistic arithmetic.
So you're able, for example,
to go into the corpus
and give it an equation.
So let's say you wanted
to see how rigorous
and extensive your corpus was,
if it was really good.
And again, this algorithm
gets more precise
the more text there is,
so the bigger your corpus is.
You could theoretically put in this query,
king plus man minus woman
and you would most likely get queen
because it's that smart
which is a little menacing
but also really interesting.
So in the Vogue corpus
just for an example,
if we put in this
algorithm or this equation,
you'll see that in 1940, 50, 60,
all of the first, the most related words,
were in fact queen.
Then interestingly in 1970,
I'm not sure why it's hairy
and the third most related word was queen
but I also thought it was kind of awesome
that in the Vogue corpus
the most related word that should be queen
is actually Thatcher in the 1980s,
just a glitch of history.
So then Zach and I were
just sort of playing around
with more queries like this
with, we have a big, big list of them
and I'm still not quite
sure what to do with them
but this interesting thing
that you can do essentially
is if you say media minus medium
and you throw that into the computer,
you'll hopefully be able to
approximate something like,
it will take away, let's say,
all of the words that are
both the most related to media
and both the most related to medium
and you'll try to get to
a different type, aspect,
element of the concept.
To me, was thinking about
when I chose these
particular ones to show you,
medium minus media, media
plus arts, media plus press,
I was trying to sort of get
at these different aspects
of the media concept,
its' relation to the concept
of medium or platform,
its relationship to the
phenomenon of mass culture,
its relationship to the article the.
So media minus press,
I was sort of trying to get at
if you take away the very
activity of the press
is there some way to get
this sort of environmental
or atmospheric quality of media
that's not actually professional
but is more sort of experiential.
I mean these are just
aspirational algorithms here
but we get some really
interesting weird stuff
like media minus medium,
the third most related word is Pachevik
who was the chairman of Conde Nast
for much of the 20th century.
So that's interesting and weird.
Again, this is just the Vogue corpus
and so where Zach and
I are going with this,
this I thought was interesting
that media plus arts over time,
you start to get these sort of
what we would think of as mediums.
So Zach and I started working
on this with the Atlantic
and I'm actually now
working with Richard So
at the McGill
who has access to the High Trust databases
and we're actually just sort of trying
to put together a huge magazine
corpus from the 20th century
and run Word2vec on that.
But you'll see that the Atlantic one
for a variety of super
interesting reasons,
just didn't quite work
in that it's not big enough.
We're only able to,
just because of time and resources,
Zach's and mine, not the DH Lab's,
we're not actually able
to get all of the text
from the Atlantic
but just the text that
had the word media in them
and that just wasn't enough text
for the Word2vec
algorithm to be effective.
So you get these really,
and the way we know that essentially,
first of all, they way you know that
is that before 1960,
there's just not even
enough text there at all
to have data.
Also, none of these are queen.
Sometimes, country,
maintain, forage, bishop,
it just didn't quite work.
So hopefully as we continue this project
and we get a bigger and bigger corpus,
we're hoping to actually
be able to approximate
the way that the media
talked about media in the 20th century.
So that's where we're at, yeah, thank you.
(audience applause)
- Thanks so much
and now I think having failed once
at being able to get the
powerpoint working correctly,
I think we now can
invite up Jasper Feinberg
to talk about coeducation at Yale
through the eyes of the pioneer,
I think I managed to get it working,
thank you Jasper.
- Thank you.
So first of all, thank you
all for being here obviously.
I'm a sophomore undergraduate at Yale
studying mechanical engineering
and actually did this project
as part of a digital
humanities class at Yale
which is a seminar offered
to all undergraduates.
I believe some of the
teachers of that actual class
are in the audience
but I won't embarrass them by
pointing at them specifically.
So the goal of this project
was to show how Yale became coeducational
but our true goal was to show
how the use of digital multimedia
could literally bring that process to life
and given the time frame,
I want to dive right into that.
So our goal was to not just sort of
give a textbook history of
Yale's process to coeducation
but to really sort of make our audience
feel a lot of the actual
struggles, discrimination
and the context of this era.
And we chose to do that
by focusing on one person in particular
as opposed to showing a broader spectrum.
That person happened to be Margaret Homans
who is currently an English professor here
and was member of the second
class of women at Yale.
But before giving a full
rundown of her story,
I just want to sort of
establish the context
of coeducation at Yale.
So as some of you may or may not know,
Yale actually did not become
coeducational until 1969
and it sort of became coeducational
as the women's movement
and broader movements at Yale
itself began to push for it.
But it should be noted
that Yale was not exactly the pioneer
despite the title of this project
in the field of coeducation.
By 1897, 56% of all institutions
were already coeducational.
By the time that Yale
actually became coeducational,
that number was in the 80 percents.
So to give sort of a map,
this is Yale obviously.
The first school to become coeducational
was Oberlin in 1837.
Once Oberlin became coeducational,
then about nine more universities
became coeducational in the 1850s
including Baylor, Lawrence, Antioch,
but the movement still had not started,
it was mostly small colleges
and the true shift towards
coeducation had not begun.
But that became much more pronounced
with the beginning of the
land grant universities,
especially in Western region
which, if you don't know,
are large public institutions
that usually began coeducational
and that really drove the push.
HBCUs as well became
coeducational in the 1800s.
Now if we fast forward a little bit,
by 1965, most schools
had become coeducational,
that included Harvard, UPenn,
many of the schools in the west
such as Stanford, Cal Tech, et cetera,
and about overall, I think 84% of colleges
were coeducational.
So by the time Yale actually
became coeducational in 1969
they were far behind most of their peers.
This was not necessarily
a great achievement
but nonetheless,
they had a very large transition to make.
Shifting a school from solely male
to a coeducational institution
is no easy transition
and that's what we wanted to focus on
through the eyes of
Margaret Homans herself
and looking at her experiences.
So with that in mind,
Margaret Homans starting
with her childhood
was born in Boston
and she actually attended
something called the Commonwealth School
which is a private school in Boston
and she credits that
with sort of her ability
to get into a place like Yale so early,
become one of the first
members of her class.
Obviously, she had privileges
that many other women did
not have during that era.
And she decided to attend Yale
not really because it had
just become coeducational
but just because of the strength
of its academic programs.
She had a teacher in high school
who had gone to Yale for English
and he sort of described to her
sort of a utopia for the English language
and studies of it.
So she chose Yale mostly just
for its academic achievements
and the fact that it
had become coeducational
allowed her to do that.
But it was not that she
desired to be a pioneer,
she simply wanted to study English.
So Yale, to give a
very, very brief history
given the time constraint,
decided to admit women in the 1960s
after a variety of student protests.
So the main factor that
shifted during this era
was that Yale's actual admission
criterion began to shift.
President Kingman Brewster
decided to begin to admit people
based on merit as opposed
to family connections,
wealth, et cetera,
which it seems like a
very obvious decision
to us at the time
but earlier in this era,
merit had been a factor
but not the main factor in admissions.
And so once merit became
the true determining factor
between who was admitted and not admitted,
then many more people
from public institutions,
public high schools, Western high schools
began to attend Yale
and that's when it produced
the demographic shift
amongst the men at Yale.
And eventually that led to protests
in what's called May Day
which was a series of protests
that tried to show Kingman Brewster
that the student body
was behind this shift towards coeducation.
So upon feeling a lot of student pressure,
faculty finally decided to get behind this
and they decided to create
proposals, et cetera,
and finally in 1969,
Yale decided to become coeducational
and again to establish some context,
this shift was not easy.
We included some multimedia here
of the letters that were
sent to Kingman Brewster.
Some calling women indignant
for showing their knees
and thighs in public,
calling them prostitutes
if they were to even
show any sort of skin,
many letters saying
that if women dominated
Yale, Yale would end,
they wanted their sons
to be able to go to Yale
and they could not do that
if women somehow attended.
So by the time Homans got here,
it was not exactly a easy transition.
And I think that's really reflected
in her anecdotes and her stories.
So starting with academics,
she describes being used
to being in a simply
coeducational environment.
To her it was not significant
that women were now in these classes.
But to many of the boys, it was.
She described being in a classroom,
especially in her English classes
and being one of only
one or two women there
and how the pressure was
always on her to speak
whenever any topic related
to femininity came up
and how outside of that she
felt very reticent to speak,
she did not feel as though she
could really develop a voice.
One of the things that
she described as lucky
was being in classrooms
with some female professors
who actually encouraged her
to study female literature
and feminist critique
and she felt like that was really
the main academic experience
as opposed to reading just books
by what she described as and
I quote, "Dead white men."
Outside of the classroom,
Homans became involved heavily
in the women's abortion
referral center at Yale
which is currently in the,
it was formerly in what
is now the AFAM House
if any of you know where that is.
She also briefly joined the Glee Club
and several other clubs on campus,
although she felt like she was usually
admitted to those clubs
solely because she was a woman
and most of the clubs
at the time had a quota
where they were supposed
to try to achieve equal gender balance.
So there was a lot of
pressure to admit women.
Some of the experiences
that I thought were most poignant however,
were just her personal experiences.
So women were all housed
in Vanderbilt Hall
during this era
and there was a glass
door to Vanderbilt Hall
and Homans described that
door as being symbolic
where she felt as though women could see
sort of the freedom they
were promised in coeducation
but they couldn't actually achieve it
because there was a guard at that door
who wouldn't let them
out at night, et cetera,
whereas none of the other halls
had a guard or such a door.
Another experience she mentioned
was how she sewed herself
what she described as a uniform
which is essentially a long dress
and she wore that every day
to essentially cover
up any part of her body
because she was not used to being
sort of viewed as a female body
as opposed to just another student
and she wanted to hide herself
and this uniform was a
way for her to do that.
And finally, she actually described
how she refused to walk
down the graduation hallway
in her cap and gown
because she felt as though
that was encouraging
an all male tradition
and she wanted to rebel.
And on the whole,
I would not describe
her transition as easy
but she was able to adapt to Yale
and find places where she was comfortable.
This heat map shows areas on campus
where she felt comfortable
and uncomfortable
and by sort of carving out
certain areas on campus,
she was able to sort of adapt,
find other women
and create an environment
in which she could learn.
But obviously looking forward,
her experiences I think
are emblematic of the
path we still have to go
to achieve true coeducation at Yale
and I just want to leave you with the idea
of what does coeducation mean?
Is it truly just having
women in our classrooms
or is it allowing a fully immersive
and equal educational experience
and how can we achieve that?
Thank you very much.
(audience applause)
- Thanks very much to Jasper.
And now I'd like to invite Nina Varsava up
who is going to speak on the relationship
between the style and
impact of judicial opinions.
- Okay, first of all, thank you so much
to the Digital Humanities Lab
for all of the help they've given me,
all the support they've
given me with my research
and thanks especially to Doug Duhine
who has helped me tirelessly
with the minutiae of this
project and related work.
I'm incredibly grateful.
I'm going to be talking
about the relationship between the style
and impact of judicial opinions.
So judicial opinions are
the texts that judges write
in order to explain and
justify their decisions
and these texts make up the common law.
When judges decide new cases,
they have a legal duty to
follow the rules and reasoning
set out in previous opinions.
The more cases that a
previous opinion appears in,
the more influence it
has on the common law.
So I examine whether and
how an opinion's style
is related to its impact,
to its legal impact.
My results show that an opinion's style
is a significant predictor
of its impact
where impact is measured
by the number of cases
that will cite it.
So to give you a brief
overview of my approach,
my dataset includes almost
all majority opinions
from the 10th circuit court of appeals
during a 12 year period.
This court is an important
federal appellate court
which answers to the US supreme court,
it's also the court where
Neil Gorsuch served as a judge
before joining the
supreme court last year.
So first I derived a set
of measurable stylistic features
from the literature on judicial writing.
I then used natural language processing
to detect and measure these features
in each of my opinions.
My dependent variable
is the number of cases
that cite the opinion
and I used this as a measure
of an opinion's impact
on case law or its power as a precedent.
My independent variables.
On the top, I've listed my
stylistic features of interest.
On the bottom are my control variables.
For the most part on
the stylistic features,
I measure these on a per word basis
meaning that for example
with citations to authority
I counted how many times an opinion
cites statutes and other cases per word.
First, I'll give you
an overview of my data
using some charts
to give you a sense of what they look like
and then I'll show my statistical model
and my statistical results.
So here you can see how judges line up
on lexical diversity.
Lexical diversity is basically
the range of vocabulary of an opinion.
It's simply the number of unique
words over the total words.
So you can see here that the judges range
from about 20% unique
words to 28% unique words.
Male judges are in blue,
female judges are in maroon
and Gorsuch is highlighted in red.
Here's informality.
This is basically informal usage per word.
And you can see here that the judges range
from about zero on
informality to about .01
which means one per 100 words is informal
with Gorsuch at the high end.
Here's certainty.
So this is terms expressing
certainty per word.
So judges range on this
from about one to 3.5 certainty
terms per 1,000 words.
And you can see the female judges
clustering on the low end of certainty
but what's interesting
is they also cluster on
the low end of hesitancy.
So this represents hesitant
or tentative expressions
and Gorsuch again is on
the high end of this.
So here is my main statistical model.
This is a mixed model
which is a type of regression
that suits the structure of my data.
To give you a summary,
my results show that stylistic qualities
run with a case's impact
or precedential power
in systematic ways.
My style variables are on the
top in the blue rectangle.
All of these variables,
all of these stylistic features
with the exception of passive voice
are statistically significant
predictors of citations.
And recall that my dependent variable
is the number of cases
that cite the opinion.
Most of these factors are
positively related to citations
but two of them,
certainty and informality,
are negative predictors of citations.
So I'll take my remaining time
to talk through these results
since it's not altogether obvious I think
just from looking at the
values what they mean
because for one, my dependent
variable is log transformed.
So as word count goes up by one,
citing cases goes up by,
sorry, as word count
goes up by one percent,
citing cases also goes
up by about one percent.
As reading level goes
up by one grade level,
citations goes up by five percent.
As lexical diversity
goes up by one percent,
cites go up by two percent.
As authority per word goes up by .01,
so this means one additional citation
to a case or statute per 100 words,
cites goes up by 27%.
As references to people by proper name
goes up by one in 100,
citing cases goes up by 20%
and that's the same for
references to litigants
by technical terms,
plaintiff or defendant.
So it seems that just referring to people
regardless of how,
is a good thing for citations.
As certainty per word goes
up by .001, one in 1,000,
citing cases goes down by four percent
but as hesitancy goes
up by the same amount,
one in 1,000,
citing cases goes up.
So certainty is a negative
predictor of citations
but hesitancy is a positive predictor.
Semicolons goes up by one in 1,000,
cite goes up by three percent.
And then as informality per
word goes up by one in 100,
citing cases goes down by 20%.
So informality is strongly
negatively related
with citations.
So to just wrap up,
I also ran a regression,
a normal regression with
judged fixed effects
which generated very similar
results to this model.
The fixed effects model
shows that my variables explain 45%
of the variance in citations
and that my stylistic variables alone,
just these 11 stylistic features
explain 15% of the variance
in the number of cases
that will cite an opinion.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
- Thanks very much to Nina.
And now I'd like to invite up
participants in our project
called Digital Humanity,
Jessica Ambrosio and Maria
Gargiulo, apologies for that.
- Good morning everyone.
My name is Jessica Ambrosio
and I'm a junior major
in computer science.
- Hi, my name's Maria Gargiulo
and I'm also a junior
majoring in statistics and
data science and Spanish
and we're the co presidents
of Yale Code For Good.
Today we're presenting on
what we call digital humanity
and we'd like to begin
with this brief anecdote.
"The first program most people write
"is a simple, hollow world.
"It's time we start seriously considering
"and talking about
"the impact that our code can
"and does have on the
world in which we live."
- So as a club we have come
to define Coding for Good
as applying tools and techniques
to solve problems that a
community or society faces.
So what this means
is that we seek to design
and develop programs
that not only address the
technical aspects of programs
but also consider
the impact that these
technologies will have
on the people who make use of them.
Is the impact positive?
Does it benefit them beyond
just merely solely
being a technical issue?
- So you might be asking now,
how do you do that?
So we do this by recruiting
teams of four to six students
to work in collaboration with
non profit organizations,
Yale student groups or
local government agencies
to address socially conscious problems.
And these can cover all
types of different things.
There's no one problem that is
or is not socially conscious,
many things are different in many ways.
We currently have three project teams,
two of who's work we'd
like to highlight today.
- So our first project
is the Roadside Manager
and for this project we
partnered with (mumbles)
in downtown New Haven
and the New Haven
Department of Transportation
to address transportation traffic issues.
The main problem to solve here
was that commuters did not know
where how many parking
spaces were available
at a given location.
To solve this problem,
(mumbles) modified the
hardware of multiple road signs
so that they could be programmable.
Nevertheless, someone still
had to go down to the roadside
and change it manually.
To this end, our team
built a web application
that connects the road signs
so that officials can simply
access the web application
and update any information on
the road sign in real time.
In addition to improving the
parking system in New Haven,
this offer also provides a great mechanism
for important updates
in case of emergencies.
If you want to hear
more about this project,
the team who worked on it
will be later presenting
during the poster session.
- The next project that we'd
like to talk about today
has been done in collaboration
with Khushi Baby.
So Khushi Baby is actually
a nonprofit organization
founded at Yale,
started in the CID as
part of a class project
for I think a mechanical
engineering course a few years ago.
It operates in India.
In founding our organization,
the Khushi Baby team sought
to address issues in the
Indian medical system.
Currently, doctors are
required to keep paper records.
An issue with these records
is that they need to travel
with the doctors as they move.
They often become disorganized
and files get lost
and this is particularly problematic
for women and their newborn children.
The issue with this
is that they need to see doctors
at certain points post birth
and if doctors are losing files,
there's no record of which
vaccinations they've received
when they've gone to past appointments.
So to deal with this, the Khushi Baby team
made a simple wearable,
it's a little necklace
that the child wears
and it stores all of
their information in it.
When doctors go to see the
children and their mothers
they can simply load their
data into a web application
if they have internet access
and if not, there's an Android app.
Multiple people can view the information
when they're seeing the child
offline whenever they need to
and this is really helpful
because it deals with
the missing record issue
and also lets people look at
information in various places.
The Code for Good team has been
contributing to this project
by helping Khushi Baby
update some of their models.
One of the big things
that the team cares about
is risk assessment.
They like to triage their patients
so that newborns and their mothers
who are particularly high risk
for various types of health issues
can be viewed according
to the relevant priority.
So yeah, and this is just a little image
of what the dashboard
of the Khushi Baby application looks like.
Now you might be asking yourself,
why do we do this, why
was Code for Good founded?
So Code for Good was founded last spring
and the reason it was founded
is because there was no real
space available on campus
for technically inclined students
to work on socially conscious problems.
- So there are a lot of wonderful places
where our students can go and work at
but the impact that they can make there
will rarely reach the people
who need their help the most.
So this is your typical job fair,
these are the kind of
companies that we usually see
that any CS or data
science major will look at
and you know what, these are
wonderful places to work at,
they are doing amazing stuff
but they only present a partial image
of what can be done with technology.
- And to end off today,
we'd like to leave you all with a question
or perhaps a challenge.
How can you do more good
with the technology that
you use or know how to use?
- So if you have an
answer to this question
or just want to share your ideas with us
please contact us at codeforgood@yale.edu.
- [Both] Thank you.
(audience applause)
- Thank you, Jessica and Maria
and to all of our presenters
during this first initial lightning talks
part of the conference.
I think at this point,
I'd like to invite up members
of our round table discussion.
(playful music)